what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Chucky season two episode two today John
how are you uh you know how are you okay
that's an answer for sure very
optimistic and positive way to bring
great energy to the video guys we are
going to do this so please go ahead and
slash that like button that would mean a
ton to us also uh full-length Reaction
watch along is where you sync up with
your own copy for Chucky available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
cover a whole bunch of shows over there
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch alongs included the first
episode of Chucky we did make public
free for you guys to watch but the rest
you know patreon also thanks to team
prep for helping set it down these
highlights we got a swing action people
thank you
[Music]
good morning sweet face rise and shine
her hair is long what was that screaming
oh I'm sorry Mika I didn't mean to
disturb you oh you chopped off my arms
and legs you lunatic we've been through
this before I cut off Chucky's arms and
legs
excuse me Nika I need to speak with him
[Music]
woof
I ate a doll
what the [ __ ] is this
I'm gonna pay
the me doll I'm gonna see you all
riding in the ground now
I forgot how good she is at that it's
good to have you back Nika then Jesus
rebuked the unclean spirit I command you
release this child what's on and never
return did they have a third brother
this is definitely again
it's a metaphor I love metaphors
I think you're right let us offer each
other the sign of peace
peace be with you
hi I'm Nadine Moaning Myrtle it's kind
of weird they don't acknowledge at all
that it looks like his dad
and her ex's Dad yeah by the way
saved a new donation morning
[Music]
don't you see him our Lord's image plain
as day right here in the Stone's face no
didn't you see his image in a taco at
lunch last week but um Jesus is
everywhere how long have you been here
since seventh grade my parents couldn't
control me
really
[Music]
damn they didn't check your bag yeah I
just think that and I'm Lexi I'm an old
friend of Trevor's hey did you know he
was born with only one testicle made
your life a living hell back in the day
for what it's worth I'm not the same
person as I was back then so who are you
someone who's not ashamed about only one
testicle I guess Manish anxiety from
your heart and cast off the Troubles of
your body for Youth and figure are
meaningless oh my God it really works
here I can only imagine what you've gone
through this past year everyone's
talking about it all those murders
eating a deranged killer and that poor
soul taken in your own home it's like a
Harry Styles Bill Skarsgard thing about
this guy you're familiar with the
surrealists a little I'm more familiar
with the way she's upset well why should
we as Catholics need to worry about this
if we can just go to confession and be
forgiven I'm gonna let you guys in on a
little secret God's not real
[Music]
foreign
you pick God up
[Music]
hi I'm Chucky
wanna pray
I like it I like it Chucky
oh my God she died with her arms out
like Christ uh
on wood she gave herself for our sins
look at him oh he's taunting us he isn't
doing anything that's what I mean
it's diabolical
[Laughter]
I have to get in there
you people lost
you're not my father I know your history
it's just a doll
I'll see you three in study hall I hope
they use a crucifix to break in
pick a lock with the Lord God reminds me
of my dad there we go finally hey meta
needed some awareness that's another
thing random child support 11 million
dollars
a liar liar you need to get out of this
house and get a job come Jennifer so you
can escape nice China [ __ ] am I gonna
Escape that reminds me my darling Glenn
and Glenda are coming by this weekend
yes oh [ __ ] we're all out of chloroform
did that happen
[Music]
it's not the game
the gay front door
ball gag it is
you cannot ruin everything what is wrong
with you
Jennifer Tilly is really good at playing
this character who is not Jennifer Tilly
but people think it's Jennifer yeah
layers on layers oh the same maybe you
would like to take a selfie with me uh
detective and you know I would love that
but I'm actually here uh because of a
missing person mystery have you ever
heard no ugh
have you ever heard no no no
silly have you ever heard of Nica Pierce
bro yes I believe I met her when I
visited that mental hospital back East
um you know
that's one of that's a reference
and you're aware of that no well shortly
after your visit she killed several
people
use the restroom I don't know can you
may I go to the restroom father
may I
manners maketh men
you have exactly five minutes
Jake I can't just
go to the bathroom in five minutes
[Music]
please
wow that's a cool shot yeah
ah you [ __ ] [ __ ] really Mr
Williams
oh
back in the old days we would have
washed your mouth out with soap we have
different methods of teaching lessons
now
you're gonna have to read a book your
first Bible is something you'll never
forget it's time for you to find a
passage that speaks to you homosexuality
is an Abomination let me check back with
you at the end period maybe you could
read me something you can't just leave
me here
do the work Jake you won't regret it
this is what you wanted
uh
gotcha no
no no
oh my God he probably knows the entire
architecture for the structure of this
place I honestly have no idea
oh no
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what have you got the door open
hide the drugs why were you screaming
because I was scared scared of what
what's going on here what's happening
look at this road got that Silk robe
where the hell could he be no
I have no idea
[Music]
oh
a little help whoa why'd you take Jake's
picture
what picture I don't know what you're
talking about
how many of you are left
you I'm not telling you [ __ ]
oh look I think I know what Chucky's up
to
[Music]
what what he's starting up at Instagram
he's kind of cyber Stock People he's
collecting information for someone
who
that's what we're gonna find out I don't
know Mega Chucky War Games Child's Play
Three protective Sam Gavin I'm sorry to
bother you again miss Tilly but
something's just not adding up
nope
respect something
yes she finds out we're working together
it's all over listen
listen I was like giallo lighting
and we're
go against
to protect someone you love
yeah actually oh yeah
not me the values are for losers
now it's time
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
they them
[Music]
[Laughter]
so nice to see your sweet faces
[Music]
oh no no
bastards damn it I knew exactly what
they were all right guys we uh She-Hulk
is airing right now we gotta hop right
to it because I gotta edit She-Hulk
tonight so uh Corey just waiting outside
for us waiting to finish him but um
let's talk quickly John take it away
yeah I'm really loving the way this
season is progressing and just the you
know each uh season as Don Mancini has
put it he wanted to have a sort of
different flavor and I really like the
flavor that this season has going on so
far I mean really getting to know this
you know Catholic boarding school that
they're all going to be set up in
getting this weird mystery with like
okay what is Chucky doing because he's
not coming at us like we would expect
him to so you know finding a new and
clever way of you know uh protracting
that tension not showing you know evil
messed up Chucky too much too soon I
think they've found a nice way to do
that and then on the opposite side
you've got you know uh uh Tiffany and
Nika back and just rejoining with them
has been really fun fun and really
twisted and getting yeah a little
Glimpse as to what's been going on with
them since we last saw them and also
what's been going on between Nika and
Chucky uh yeah just the whole tapestry I
really enjoy the array of you know bits
and pieces that they're setting up to
topple over this season and uh yeah
excited to see what some of the new cast
people bring as well how about you what
do you think I liked it I think they you
know with Don Mancini he's been bringing
a lot of cool filmmaking flourishes uh
ever since like Curse of Chucky Cult of
Chucky and then now this you get to see
a lot more because I don't think he
directed this particular episode right
no it was a different director but still
you know he's got his fingerprints all
over it and you can imagine he is still
someone who Shepherds a lot of the way
the uh the imagery of all this should
look and I like the way that they've
been composing a lot of their shots for
this and getting a different Flair for
the religious horror I am finding myself
in a stage room like I am waiting to see
what makes this
being in the boarding school the
religious quality of it like there's so
many movies that have done it with no
matter if it's a drama or horror and I'm
waiting for the thing that really makes
this stand out as different because
sometimes the dialogue of demonstrating
the parts of why it sucks here it feels
a little cliche like a lot of the things
feel very very cliche granted you know I
mean they're
fathers and nuns you know priests and
nuns and I don't know much more
different can you really get so I'm
waiting for that part to really seep
through of feeling like this is unique
for the Chucky world right now versus I
kind of feel like I've seen this a bunch
and now it's just in the Chucky world
you know that's the part I want to see
but as it stands I am really enjoying um
I don't know the actor's name it took me
a while to even recognize him uh Devin
Sawa Devin Sawa uh it's cool bringing
him back here uh into the show because
he is doing something very different I
mean he played the twins very different
and with just write enough similarities
to distinguish it they are brothers
Still and here you know I I didn't even
recognize him at first those damn
glasses Clark Kent was right uh is that
George Romero glasses yeah but how he
brings that to life is because when you
first see him he does seem like ah you
know what it seems like the nuns are the
annoying ones and you'd be all the all
right guy maybe you're the one who uh
can be the the one who can actually
bring some kind of warmth to this show
and you might be an all right guy but I
noticed like there are a lot of those
Sinister types of music cues where
there's a tension in the music cues when
he's there and whether it's a plan the
emotions of someone like Jake or the
students the other students I I feel
like there's something
perhaps underlying Sinister about him
that they give kind of these like little
looks towards because yeah he slowly was
becoming someone I'm like okay I don't
trust this guy actually I don't trust
him there's some there's something about
him to to have a big question mark
towards and then there's other hints too
you know of that there's something more
at play here with the Trevor character
showing that you know as much as he's
given himself to God
I don't know about this I don't feel I
feel like there's something uh you know
maybe there's another cult thing going
on here because then the nun when she
sees the good guy dolls like our image
you know like yeah she lights up at the
side of him so perhaps there's going to
be some type of unveiling that shows oh
there's it's not really about
Catholicism and God like if we're gonna
play with that at first but then we're
gonna find out there's something even
more revolting going on around here you
know well that's why I remain at least a
little cautiously I have to miss it
because yeah you're right like a lot of
the stuff at the outset is a little bit
like you're Classic we're in Catholic
territory now priests and nuns and blah
blah blah dialogue and whatnot but what
was what I appreciate about the first
season in its attack on like bullying
and stuff like that is yeah you have
these characters who appear one way at
first but as we go you know it utilizes
the length of the season to surprise you
and twist and turn you in terms of yeah
what characters reveal and stuff so I'm
hoping that you know we get surprised by
who might be more benevolent or
malevolent yeah then they appear right
now because of course to our main
characters everyone's going to appear a
bit sus I think well and now we have
Glenn and Glenda here and I don't think
we've seen them since the end of Seed of
Chucky which is kind of yeah right
confusing I've ever been a little bit
confused at what happened there because
like it was like clearly Glenda chooses
who they are and then okay but she
actually had the babies and some people
seemed it's artificial I'm a little bit
uh yeah I don't know it was confusing to
me even though I had only seen her
recently I was like a little bit of a
question mark which has happened here
but all right sure I'm just choosing to
take it as yeah they they separated the
two Spirits from The Glenn or Glenda
puppet body the gentle Glenn body and
yeah just put him in the two kids they
artificially since seven dated Jennifer
Tilly with I mean don't get me wrong I
can roll with it easily I can I can
easily roll with it but when I overthink
it then I start to get a little confused
by the rules of what happen here but
either way I'm excited to see
um what happens there with Glenn and
Glenda you know and I I did like the
reveal when Nika talking with Chucky and
cooperating with him with their own mind
and I like the distinguishing filmmaking
flourish like you pointed out gelato
um with the red lights and then the
Dutch angles and such it was a clever
way to show in her mind right now and
because yeah she seems so submissive and
then to show that okay there is a a
deeper thing there there is some French
film I saw I saw like a a whole
breakdown of it I think it was a French
movie about that where like someone has
kept hostage that way and she just amped
in a box in a box with no limbs I don't
know it was a box but they amputate okay
this guy amputates all of her limbs off
and then she develops Stockholm syndrome
and falls in love with him and oh it's
really messed up like one of those
French I believe it was a French movie
there's some type of foreign
David Lynch's daughter has a movie
that's similar to that where it's like
someone with no arms and no legs who's
being like imprisoned in a box or
something like that with a twisted
psychological angle on it but yeah well
either way uh I like seeing I like I
like having Nico back here and Jennifer
Tilly is is just a constant reminder of
just a wonderful addition that seems
like it could have because that was such
a turning point for the Chucky franchise
Bride of Chucky
and she has been such a constant though
as something great that no matter what
way we want to move with the flow of how
Chucky franchise is going her presence
is always something that is so welcoming
and she was so hilarious here at the
same time yeah you know and I like some
of the teases with the in the Catholic
school with Jake you know perhaps being
a little bit drawn towards it because
maybe you can find some type of
Salvation I'd like if there's a little
bit of a play here where he is able to
find some type of forgiveness within
himself
um but I don't know there's more to
unpack and I think it was a great
episode again I think there's another
really solid installment I am waiting
for some more of those unique flourishes
but not to say that there were still
some fairly unique stuff throughout I
still thought it was a really really
enjoyable episode I love the
performances all around and shouts out
to the actor plays Jake again because
God damn is he is he phenomenal I love
that scene when they close the door you
could see it the whole time he's been
containing the overwhelming emotions of
of guilt and sadness and just burst into
tears and uh yeah hats off to Zachary I
like a lot of The Logical acknowledgment
too like when Devin kicks Chucky I'm
like thank you there you go yeah
everyone's always afraid to get into a
fight with this guy yeah dude he's the
one who's like we got to stand our
ground you know yeah so yeah another
solid episode
um and uh yeah keep a lookout for
erection the next one guys subscribe
click that Bell leave a like talk to
y'all soon
[Music]